[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrante es el
programa semanal de france 24 sobre el
éxodo mi nombre es juliette riaño y los
saludos desde casa
[Música]
el último año del mundo fue puesto a
prueba tras la llegada del cob y 19 un
virus desconocido que paralizó todas las
actividades y provocó el cierre de
fronteras para contener su propagación
lo que no se detuvo fue la huida de
miles de personas que tuvieron que dejar
sus hogares en busca de seguridad a
finales de 2020 82,4 millones de hombres
mujeres niñas y niños fueron desplazados
forzosamente un número récord en tiempos
en que las rutas para el tránsito fueron
menores a propósito del día mundial del
refugiado y desplazado acnur presentó un
informe global en el que detalló la
situación de los que huyen en el mundo
más del 68 por ciento de los refugiados
y desplazados en el extranjero proceden
sólo de cinco países siria venezuela
afganistán sudan del sur y mianmar
el desplazamiento forzado es un drama al
que muchas tienen que hacer frente ya
sea por conflictos armados o persecución
política actualmente al menos 82 como 4
millones de personas en todo el mundo se
han visto obligadas a huir de sus
hogares en el caso de los refugiados
fuera de las fronteras de sus países y
en el de los desplazados dentro de la
misma nación en busca de una mejor vida
en otros territorios
muchos se han topado con otra realidad
vivir en campos de refugiados o
comunidades separadas como única opción
un problema que afecta especialmente a
países como siria golpeada por una
guerra que los expertos tachan como la
peor crisis humanitaria de los últimos
tiempos o venezuela donde se vive una
profunda crisis económica repartidos por
el mundo la mayoría de los refugiados
intentan llegar a naciones vecinas
aunque la carga de acogida es
tremendamente desigual en 2020 los
países más desarrollados tan solo dieron
acogida al 19% de los refugiados
mientras que las naciones en desarrollo
tuvieron que alojar al 27 por ciento de
la población refugiada gran parte de los
67 millones de sirios en condición de
refugiados están en países como turquía
o alemania y en el caso de los
venezolanos el destino más común es
colombia territorio fronterizo la crisis
de migrantes y refugiados se extiende
también por zonas como el mediterráneo a
diferencia de los refugiados los
migrantes no abandonan sus países por
peligro de muerte sino que buscan
mejorar su calidad de vida
un matiz a veces difícil de distinguir
por otro lado acnur advierte que el 42
por ciento de los refugiados tienen
menos de 18 años muchos sufren abusos un
problema humanitario que desde naciones
unidas- insisten se debe solucionar con
la colaboración de todos los países
desarrollados del mundo
y precisamente uno de los países que
tomó medidas en beneficio de los
migrantes y refugiados en el último año
fue colombia gracias al estatuto
temporal de protección esperar
regularizar a más de 18 millones de
venezolanos una política migratoria que
le permitirá a miles de personas
pertenecer a un país que no es el suyo
veamos a continuación tres historias de
migrantes y refugiados en los países de
acogida
esta calle en el norte de bogotá hace de
oficina para charly y edílson
venezolanos ambos trabajan por ahora
como artistas callejeros pero esperan
que pronto puedan aplicar a vacantes
acordes a su profesión gracias al
estatuto temporal de protección que les
abrirá las puertas laborales en colombia
tengo mucha ilusión con este proyecto
migratorio porque
deseo establecerme como tal acá
yo no tengo pensado volver a junio de
2021 más de 968.000 venezolanos se
inscribieron para comenzar el proceso
que les permitirá regularizar su
situación y así aportar con su profesión
en el país que los acoge
mientras tanto en bangladesh la
comunidad rojilla busca la forma para
documentar lo que pasa en el campo de
refugiados de cox pasar y están
aprendiendo a hacerlo a través de
fotografías de la comunidad 60 advirtió
que de verdad quiero mostrarle al mundo
entero cómo vivimos aquí como la gente
está muriendo a causa de incendios y
deslizamientos de tierra
camps el molde marván y fortalece y como
los niños están siendo educados y
estudian árabe en las escuelas del
campamento
desde enero de 2020 la escuela de cine
de omar busca capacitar a los jóvenes
rojilla para que puedan ejercer como
fotógrafos profesionales y quien ya
puede ejercer en su país de acogida es
el doctor samuel doll un refugiado
sursudanés que llegó a banda cuando era
adolescente huyendo de la guerra y con
el sueño de convertirse en médico fue el
primero en su familia en obtener un
título universitario
considerar en la webcam from teniendo en
cuenta de dónde vengo yo mis padres
estaban realmente emocionados incluso
tuvieron que viajar todo el camino venir
desde el campo de refugiados para
presenciar mi graduación porque ese fue
el primer grado de la familia mi madre
nunca pudo ir a la escuela
ahora trabaja en un prestigioso hospital
de kampala atendiendo a pacientes
diagnosticados con kobe 19 es ser
refugiado no es un castigo es una
oportunidad para continuar con tus
sueños fuera de tu país
quiere especializarse en neurocirugía y
espera volver a sudán del sur y trabajar
allí como conferencista donde su
testimonio será su principal carta de
presentación hay medidas
durante la pandemia los refugiados
cubren plazas en el sector salud
necesarias y de esa forma retribuyen a
sus comunidades de acogida y sobre la
pandemia hay una tarea pendiente el
acceso equitativo a las vacunas en el
que los refugiados sean incluidos hasta
que migrantes de france24 recuerden
comentar en nuestras redes sociales con
el hashtag migrantes f24 sigan con más
información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]